One of the consequences of Moore's Law and the performance improvements that
we expect to follow is the so-called memory wall. Here's why we have it.
The processor speed in terms of instructions per second we have already said is,
can be expected to roughly double every, let's say two years. Memory capacity,
which is how many gigabytes of memory can we have in the same size module,
is also doubling every two years. But
memory latency, that is how long does it take to do a memory operation,
has only been improving about 1.1 times every two years.
So over time, as years go by, if we plot the speed of processors and
memory, we get something like this, an exponential curve for the processors.
And we get another exponential curve, but that grows a lot slower, for
memories. This here is the gap between processor performance and
memory performance at some time and then several years later,
we have a much wider gap. This problem is often called the memory wall.
Basically, our processors are getting a lot faster than memories are, yet
they have to access memory every so many instructions. And
because this difference in speed has been growing very quickly over many years,
we have been using caches as a sort of stairs for the memory wall. So
our processors now are accessing caches, which are fast, and
only those rare accesses that's missing the cache will end up going to the slow
main memory. We will spend several lessons talking about how to do caches and so
on, but this is just one of the trends that we have to worry about when we
design processors, is that they do get faster. But if the memory doesn't get
faster as quickly as they do, we have to continuously keep improving our caches
just to allow the processors to not suffer from the much, much slower memory.